[Music]
everybody who's talking about AI is so
bad like all this like these articles
were written about machinery around
farming we just knew that we were all
farming we went on to do other [ __ ] and
by the way like I don't feel bad for a
truck driver who isn't reading headlines
for 20 years
that autonomous trucks are coming we
gave him 20 [ __ ] years like when they
cry in 2039 like oh the [ __ ]
autonomous trucks took me out I'm like
dick you had 20 years you couldn't have
learned another skill along the way
[ __ ]
you got your perspective
wanna be happy don't you want to be
happy thank you thank you
the Knicks didn't get Zion so I'm dead
so energy is gonna be down at least one
solid notch
thanks for having me I've been really
looking forward to this event for a lot
of different reasons really took note of
the merger or the acquisition a year ago
as some of you may know I started my
career in the liquor business I was an
immigrant born in the former Soviet
Union kind of cliche story my dad was a
stock boy in a liquor store and after
not spending any money for a decade
eventually bought a small store and in
1996 I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in America so
this is a space that I'm really excited
about over the last decade I've been
running a company my brother AJ and I
started called the vaynermedia where
we've been working with fortune 5,000
companies around their marketing
behaviors and I think it's a really
interesting time to be here today for a
lot of different reasons whether you're
a service provider an agency or a
retailer the mix of the people in this
room you know when I when I speak I
think one thing that's really helped me
have a speaking career as I try to
reverse engineer in the room try to
bring the most value I have no clue what
I'm about to talk about for 45 minutes
like it's really a scream of
consciousness of what's actually
happening and if I understand the makeup
of the room how do I bring the most
value and that's what's really worked
for me and and that's what I'm gonna do
here now because I think what's super
interesting is for a lot of people in
this room as I kind of take a look at it
you know we're this really interesting
inflection point where internet and
consumer behavior is that complete and
utter scale and what that means is we're
really into a new era of opportunity you
know to me the white space that
technology continues to create and
always will is really a thing that most
businesses and
people struggle with because the reality
is is that most people think about
things based on what has already
happened instead of being able to
understand what's about to happen which
is ironic because what's about to happen
is already happened in history many
times over it just you have to
understand the pattern recognition and
deploy it against the current state and
so for me if you understood that jargon
for me what is really interesting is
that no matter who you are in this room
today the one thing I know we can talk
about is attention of the person you're
trying to reach my entire career I've
come to realize has been pretty simple
I've been chasing the attention of who
I'm trying to reach and that has worked
for me since I was six years old you
know probably my favorite
entrepreneurial story for me about me to
myself like in my own head is when I
started my lemonade stand business I
commenced manipulated my friends to work
the you know lemonade stands themselves
I kind of scoured the streets of Edison
New Jersey and if you think about how
sick or interesting what I'm about to
say is it was interesting to me it was
fun for me to stand on the grassy knoll
or on the corner and spend hours
watching cars drive by to try to figure
out which tree or which pole was the
best one for me to put my lemonade sign
on to sell more lemonade that was
intriguing to me that was exciting for
me and 37 years later I stand here in
front of you in the same place which is
where is the attention of who I'm trying
to reach I've now lived
Moke you know two hardcore careers that
really map this room the first 15 years
of my career was hardcore consumer right
brick-and-mortar store internet business
at scale you know I I built wine library
on the back of email mark how many
people here have done or do email
marketing in their careers just raise
your hands just high please this is just
me fun for me to say like in 1996
I had a 300,000 person email newsletter
that had 93 percent open rates and I
built my dad's business from a three to
a sixty million dollar business in a
seven year period with no cash infusion
no VC not even a credit line and it was
because I made every penny work like a
dollar and in 1996 that was actually
having a website when everybody else was
sending catalogs in the mail that was
having an email newsletter which you
know for the kids in a room like you
don't understand like people thought the
whole internet was a fad let alone email
marketing right and then later the one
that really scaled me which was the day
Google AdWords started I bought ads at
five cents a click and owned every
[ __ ] wine term in the world and and
its really interesting what we're at
some point I'm gonna mention this I
would argue that one of the things that
drives me tremendously is the greatness
of my career during the great success of
my career I was so right about Google
AdWords but I'd never been through a
pattern of buying very underpriced
attention at scale that I didn't spend
enough money on Google AdWords like when
I still you know some of you and I know
some of you that I know well like when
you hear three to sixty I'm very proud
of that but genuinely I know I left a
hundred million in revenue on the table
because I did too much Direct Mail radio
television outdoor a mix of media when I
you know it's funny to say this in Vegas
I don't play poker but there's something
that's very easy to understand when you
have the best hand and you know it you
go all-in I knew I had the best hand
with AdWords I I just I just didn't like
loonie phrase in hindsight I had the
best hand I knew it was great I just
didn't know how great it was and so you
could imagine when consumer mobile
social internet came along the pattern
recognition that I learned about email
which then became about Google AdWords
then I started the first law
legitimately one of the first ten
long-form YouTube shows in the first
months of YouTube which is a 20 minute
show of me tasting wine yeah best gig I
ever had in my career
i sat in front of a camera up for 25
minutes strength 4 bottles of wine and
it completely changed the course of my
career but what that was the first time
I learned that organic non paid media
could impact my business and so it's
really been one long game for me to get
to this moment of understanding it's the
same reason that I'm pot committed
completely obsessed with the tollbooth
that The Voice devices are gonna be in
our society in a decade the amount of
transactions and decisions that will be
made through Google home or alexa
because it's gonna save us time and we
will always choose convenience there's a
really fun time for me in our society
where everybody's talking about privacy
and I actually know that you don't give
a [ __ ] about privacy I mean it humans
prove it every single day but we care
about time and we love convenience and
so got you go and so what I really want
to try to talk about is couple things
for my own cadence to know where I want
to go with this talk how many people
here are in b2b raise your hands
my shout and b2c alright ok
so I'm gonna talk about both you know
I'll start with b2b if you're in this
room I'm extremely excited right now I'm
flabbergasted what's transpired over the
last six months on LinkedIn LinkedIn's
behavior on organic reach on content if
nobody follows you if you've never
posted a piece of content on LinkedIn
your ability tonight probably not cause
you're gonna go out but when you get
back home to put a piece of content
whether in long-form written word in
video or uploading an audio file the
amount of organic reach that post will
get if you have even a couple of hundred
connections on LinkedIn would blow your
mind it's most similar to 2007 2009
Twitter its most similar actually to
2011 to 2013 Facebook and I couldn't be
more passionate for the whole room
because what's been even more
interesting to me as I've gone deep in
the last six months even non-business
content like if you sell meal plans
posting on LinkedIn right now
is remarkable organic reach and I
couldn't be more passionate definitely
to push everybody who's in the b2b world
here because the ROI on acting like a
media company and not an advertiser on
LinkedIn I'll get into that minute is
staggering and genuinely will go away
because this is one big game of cat and
mouse one big game of cops and robbers
the organic reaches through the roof
right now people you know early adaptors
like me feel it we start working it it
starts getting talked about this from
starts doing it just supplying the man
of attention it starts growing add price
adds start penetrating in and prices
start going up and then the marketplace
becomes proper like Google AdWords is
today compared to 2002 it's really
probably the most exciting thing that's
happened to a b2b company like it's very
difficult when you're a b2b to not be a
sales driven organization it's very
difficult and so the ability to not be
completely sales and to be in actual
marketing is a remarkable opportunity
and so instead of the cliche over
spending a conferences for your booths
for print advertising in the b2b
magazine for all the cliche dumb [ __ ]
the b2b marketers do to have a moment
where you can get to scale and what I
mean by scale is the great the great
misunderstanding of today's marketing
landscape is that the breakthrough is
the ability to produce creative at scale
that is contextual to the decision maker
that you're trying to reach the number
one shortcoming of the consumer product
marketers in here and the b2b marketers
is there's not enough volume of
different creative that is contextual to
who you're trying to reach people spend
so much time in today's world around the
math and the arbitrage in our business
world today is around the art the math
is so good
the data is so clean that it becomes
commoditized over time the variable of
success for most people in this room is
the content that is being put into those
pipes and so as an opening kind of like
call to arms
please get serious about LinkedIn please
it is it
we'll go away it's remarkable and here's
the key when you fill it with content
you must act like a media company not as
an advertiser or salesperson the only
way you will penetrate in a world of
this much content being put out is by
putting out something that brings value
to your target audience not in the form
of a sales pitch which is what 98% of
the content that fills these pipes is
everybody's putting their pamphlet and
their sales pitch in there and what you
need to become is somebody who has the
ability to say hey CIO
here are 11 things that are happening in
your world that will save you money that
might not even have anything to do with
your SAS product but bring so much value
to the other person on the other end
that it becomes awareness for what
you're actually doing there's not been a
piece of content that I put out actually
is a remarkable story based on the
context I just created when I started
Wine Library TV in 2006 February 21st
2006
when I sent one of my stock guys to Best
Buy to buy a camera to put up an episode
I literally thought I was gonna do QVC
like my hope lightning I mean I'm [ __ ]
wine retailer like I was gonna make
videos and sell people stuff and so the
camera goes on and within 30 seconds
it's funny for me I actually looked at
the first episode the other day and like
you know when you know yourself like I
could see the moment where I was like oh
[ __ ] maybe I shouldn't just peddle wine
on this because I had this crazy thing I
don't know if you guys remember if they
still do this like Dateline or Nightline
like you know we're like the guy rolls
up with you on you on a mic and you're
like oh [ __ ] and they're like did you
and I was like for some reason while I
was doing this video I had this weird
image of me being at like some cocktail
party and somebody rolling up on me and
being like Gary B what do you think
about this wide and me tasting and being
like oh this is [ __ ] and I'm like you
[ __ ] said it was awesome on Wine
Library TV so
so for some reason literally in episode
1 literally within the first minute I
switched what I've been planning for
weeks in theory and then just kind of
acted on to decide to become America's
wine guy instead of selling wine from my
store it was the greatest thing that
happened to me because it became
foundational to everything I've become
everything that I see working in
marketing it's all supply and demand in
a world where everybody's putting out
content you have to imagine the best
content wins this is the cream coffee
analogy it's very simple the fact that
99% of people are eliminated from even
having a chance of being successful on
social and digital content because it's
selfish creative it's selfish content
has been a big opportunity and a big
thing that has really worked for me and
others so what's amazing about b2b and
one more time b2b hands please real
quick what's amazing about b2b is you
actually know who the decision-maker is
of your business you know the title you
know the company's b2b is I'll be very
frank I think b2b is easier to sell in I
mean it's less decision makers like
there's nothing's easy I understand that
but when the whole world potentially can
drink your wine or wear your sneakers or
toothbrush or cereal there's a lot of
muck in that there's an incredible
advantage to know what your target is
when you actually actually try to
provide that target value in a world
where they're getting sold to 24/7 365
you will see remarkable remarkable
opportunities and for most of you you
have a hardcore sales organization you
don't need your marketing to do more
sales you need your marketing to do more
brand to support your sales organization
I know that doesn't play because most
tech and most b2b companies care about
numbers every [ __ ] 90 days and
everything's so short-term and everybody
burns out their long like value out of
such short-term goals of like raising
more capital for the next round and what
we're really living through now is one
big game of Fame financial arbitrage to
hit metrics to get more veg
capital not actually build businesses I
understand that that's what's happening
it thank you
it's I got like a hundredth of a clap
from somebody outside and I was like yes
I'll take it because and I'll tell you
why it was an interesting point I wanted
to make because there's founders in this
room who are literally living their
entire life predicated on hitting
metrics for venture capital not actually
building a product and service for a
business and that will always fail
everything is easy when there's a lot of
money in the system when that money
stops the market behavior takes over and
if you didn't actually build a business
you lost so that's a he'd and hopefully
like history can tell you because this
happens every time and we're very frothy
right now there's lots of money and it's
been a long time of froth as a matter of
fact what's really most interesting
after these now eleven years of economic
boom if you're an entrepreneur in
today's day and age and you're not doing
well you suck so anyway anyway b2b
companies there's a lot of you in here
please start a podcast
it's an owned and operated property you
own the attention due enormous amount of
LinkedIn organic marketing let alone
paid but LinkedIn has a floor unlike
Facebook and Google so I do think
sometimes the the ads can be overpriced
on its merit the organic is ridiculous
bless you but the biggest thing that
everybody has to leave here with is what
you fill the pipes with the pipes are
done the pipes are dumb my favorite
thing right now in society is people
blaming social media for anything there
is no social media there's just humans
filling it with garbage so it's time for
us to take accountability for social
media we're the ones talking
we're the ones posting they're just
empty pipes the what we feel what pipes
with is the variable and so you know by
the way real quick just because this is
a fun social commentary and I see the
demo in this room the only thing more
fun to me going on right now than people
blaming social media when we're the one
filling social media is the people that
[ __ ] on Millennials when they're the
parents who created them thought that
might play some believable these kids
are so entitled you gave them an eighth
place trophy man see this is what
happens this is what happens [ __ ]
America is amazing at blaming everybody
but themselves economy collapses it's
the bank's fault really Rick you were
making eighty six thousand dollars a
year you had $100,000 in college loan
debt paying double-digit interest and
you thought it was a good idea to buy a
BMW and a $500,000 home and this is how
I think about everything which is what
leads me to the consumer marketing the
b2b marketing in this room the the
reality is very simple this is just
pretty much very basic math the
attention on Facebook Twitter Instagram
YouTube LinkedIn is grossly underpriced
versus the attention you can buy
elsewhere on outdoor radio television
you know it's basic the reason most
people in this room and then the world
don't succeed in them is they don't know
how to fill it they don't know how to
use it the ROI of a basketball is a
billion dollars for LeBron James he
knows what to do with it the ROI of a
basketball for me is about negative
8,000 because I've torn both my meniscus
right so to me what another thing I
would love to leave here with that I
think would benefit a lot of people's
businesses is understanding why I'm
giving you that analogy all the people
that made fun of me about email and
Google AdWords then became the people
that I surpassed and everybody other
sector did the same right please
recognize what's happening one more time
b2c customers
companies the people Instagram story ads
let's just get one quick thing out the
way Instagram store
he adds if you target fifteen to fifty
five-year-old consumers at all are such
an uncomfortable deal that it like makes
me laugh how slow the world is to fill
the proper Marketplace on the back of
media agencies not wanting to buy that
media because they don't make as much
margin as they do on programmatic black
box buying and so we need to take
advantage of that so I highly recommend
and again I don't know the makeup or the
remit of every single person in this
room but one of the things that has to
happen for any of the things I'm talking
about is for you to be educated not you
outsourcing it to somebody else and for
me communication and that's what we're
talking about anybody in this room and
when I look at it plenty of career and
years ahead of so many anybody in this
room who is not a practitioner of the
current state of communication and
society is vulnerable I believe not
knowing how to produce content for the
seven or eight platforms that completely
dictate the opinions of society today
not knowing how to use them how to make
content for it how the ad product works
is a vulnerability in the same way of
not knowing how to balance your
checkbook if you do not know how to
communicate you were vulnerable and so
again especially for you of ambition in
this room 20 hours of Google work people
like yeah how do I place an Instagram
story ad enter three three minutes then
you know how the details are a commodity
the strategy around what's actually
happening in our society is the variable
the reason audio is going to win for the
next decade is I don't know if you heard
we're busy as [ __ ] and what we love
about audio is when you're on the
treadmill or walking the dog or flying
to this conference you can consume the
amount of people who consume my video
content on YouTube now only in audio
form literally put the phone down and
just listen passive audio consumption is
going to continue to compound in value
the reason I want everybody here to
start a podcast is cuz you're gonna have
the attention of the end consumer then
what you fill it with will be the
variable of your success your podcast
sucks
nobody's gonna listen your podcast is
good you're gonna make money it's not
super complicated it's always been the
same thing what's happening right this
minute literally May 20 19 is the scale
of the attention is remarkable the fact
that I can run pre-roll YouTube video
ads against what people are searching
for an intent on Google is remarkable
the fact that you can make videos
literally you can start a video of like
are you looking for a home in Texas and
they're literally about to watch a
skiing video and they're like do you
want me are you buying a home in Texas
and like [ __ ] I am this is why people
get freaked out like I'm spying on me I
feel like tape on the [ __ ] webcam you
know that's spying on you dick you
searched for a home in Texas on Google
Google owns YouTube it's basic out here
this isn't the Russians this is the
greatest era of headline reading and non
practitioner ship there's an enormous
amount of executives here who control
decision-making around these new
platforms and where dollars go where
they've made a decision based on reading
five articles but I've never run an ad
in any of these platforms have decided
that Facebook can't drive their business
have decided that nobody's on snapchat
anymore
if you have a consumer business that is
trying to reach fifteen to thirty year
olds snapchat is maybe the best deal in
marketing right now it's so under priced
cuz everybody wrote it off because the
stock is doing poorly but the amount of
attention 15 to 24 is uncomfortably high
and the ad product is uncomfortably
inexpensive LinkedIn Google search
queries turned into pre-roll YouTube
where you can make videos that
completely address who you're trying to
reach Facebook on and on and on it's all
one game of the math will get you in
front of every person that you want to
get in front of this game is not a text
that game this game is not an analytics
game this game is an anthropology human
behavior what video
picture and audio do you make once you
know you're in front of somebody game
all this tech is actually commoditizing
the tech the next decades frontier is a
battle of art the next decades battle is
actually understanding the psychology of
the individual the commodity of getting
in front of somebody is gonna be basic I
love one creep a big day to get him like
and Big Data means yet until you do
something with it and then once you get
in front of somebody everybody's gonna
have the same first party data there's
too much activity you're gonna it's all
commodity and everybody thinks that's
where the game is it's just like six
years ago when everyone's like Gary I'm
gonna make my kid a coder I'm like she's
gonna make no money what do you mean I'm
like the coders that make 200 thousand a
year now easy is because they were nerds
when nobody else was doing it it was a
supply and demand issue if everybody's
on stem and the coder it becomes a
commodity it's the same thing humans did
with farming it's the same thing than
everybody it's over and over and over
again and so my friends please heed this
call I could be wrong but this is one
very strong point of view of somebody
who's in the trenches daily on these
platforms you know one thing I'm most
proud of for my thousand-person agency
is I'm the best practitioner at the
craft that we do I'm not a CEO that's in
an ivory tower I'm making every day I'm
reading every comment in my community I
do the quant based you know quick scuse
me qual based data analyzing which
allows me to then know what the next
piece of content should be based on the
opinions of the audience I'm doing that
and what I can tell you right now is
we're living in a golden era where the
reason you see such big brands
especially in e-commerce to go like
right to it we're seeing brands go from
zero to a hundred million revenue on the
back of a hundred percent influencer
marketing play I laugh when people like
guys we literally we know this I mean I
assume a lot of you know this in a room
there are literally brands that are
going from zero to 30 zero to 50 there
270 million dollars in sales in 18
months on a hundred percent Instagram
influence for execution how much
attention do you think is going on in
there to be able to do that this is the
only thing
and see if I can find it so the only
thing that matters and the only thing
that matters is such a definitive
absolute statement it's obviously not
fully fully true but Jesus if you do not
know how to communicate on the eight
platforms that dominate the screens of
every one of these devices you are
becoming irrelevant and so what excites
me is the moment we sit in today what
excites me is that we're in this moment
and the reality is it's actually
stunningly not difficult it's more of a
religious shift than it is a tactical
shift if you're sitting in this room and
you've made decisions of these platforms
but you've never run ads on it to look
at it you need to run ads on it to look
at it and whether that's for your
business or literally you try to sell
something that you buy in bulk at five
below and you list it on your platform
or list it on Facebook marketplace a
agenda I don't care how you do it
understand what's actually happening and
what you'll discover once you become a
practitioner not somebody who's just
philosophical about this stuff what
you'll discover is this is a
uncomfortable time of opportunity if you
know how to fill the pipes and the way
to fill the pipes is very simple
unless you're deploying disproportionate
selflessness or entertainment you will
lose if you look at your apps if
everybody pulled out their phone right
now and I know a lot of you plug your
phone right out and looked at your home
screen you will see that the apps which
is the clearest indication I'm literally
the easiest way for me to know who you
are is to grab your phone and see what
your home screen is it's the insight of
the world like are you anal and
everything is all you know like you know
like who are you and what you'll notice
if you look at your apps right now is
it's either entertainment or its utility
it's bringing you value
you're either got a sports app that lets
you escape that you hate your [ __ ]
job and this is why you love the [ __ ]
Knicks who can never win the [ __ ]
lottery
[Applause]
or it's a calendar or a weather app or
uber its utility or entertainment how
many people here follow my content at
all appreciate thank you Jesus thank you
so this will make tons of sense to you
that's all I do
utility entertainment I tend to blend
them into one thing its utility or
entertainment 95% of the content I see
online is a sales pitch there's a humble
brag nobody gives a [ __ ] that you got a
new watch so so please understand the
framework that it's working for
businesses for a lot of the consumer
people here another segue that I want to
go into the reason I'm pushing you so
aggressively into the art the art is the
only thing that's gonna save you as your
CAC prices continue to go up and your
CAC and LTV are upside down unless you
raise more capital if you're a consumer
if you're a retailer consumer product
and here selling in retail a lot of
people have grown quite a bit because of
ads but the problem is the cost of
acquisition continues to rise as more
people figure this out and your LTV
continues to decline or stay stable and
the only thing that will stop you
because normally you'll become
one-dimensional and you're either
dominating on facebook or dominating on
Instagram the only thing that gets you
out of the vicious cycle that has put
people out of business in the last two
downturns is the ability to understand
the art that changes the math around
your CAC and LTV the amount of people in
this room that are continuously running
the same thing because it works for
their numbers now but the number one
thing they should be doing is taking 20%
of their marketing spend out of what's
working and continuously trying to taste
new things is such an unbelievably non
natural thing for most people but it's
absolutely anecdote to the inevitable
downfall of 90% of the brands that are
winning right now in the marketplace and
so I highly recommend that actually
here's something interesting a little
bit of a hot take I think America is
ready to be
next at scale around selling and I think
it's I'm super-pumped because as a
marketer my goal is to ruin every
platform that's what we do and so if you
haven't started your aggressive text
platform where you're literally selling
on text I think we're ready and we've
been seeing some platforms emerge it
seems as though the carriers are
starting to get ready to play because
they see the advantage of taking some of
the attention away from social and other
places and starting to build up your
data around your consumers phone number
with the complete and utter intent to
text them products and services and
offerings I think is here I think for a
long time and you think about yourselves
we've protected the cell phone number
because we [ __ ] up the email address
right right I mean that's what we did
right and but I've been fascinated by
what's happened over the last 24 months
I think a lot of things got busy and you
know just the evolution of consumer
behavior and so I highly recommend for a
lot of you to really give that a real
consideration I would also recommend if
you want to have any prayer because it
is a place where people are a little
more tentative that the first 10 to 15
things you do brings disproportionate
value to the consumer so that they get
comfortable and see that if there is an
incredible you know for example Wine
Library we're about to really Road out
roll it out aggressively on text
everything's free shipping every time
always it's just a better place to buy
from than our email or website so that's
another kind of thing that I'm seeing
kind of pulse on that I'm very excited
about and and just because I've been
doing it for a while now like the open
rates and the conversion rates our email
1997 and and that's and that's it I'm
basic you know which tree was gonna be
better to sell lemonade right which
table at a baseball card show was more
likely to have the most foot traffic you
know like what the first week is a 14
year old working in my dad's liquor
store bagging at the register I started
fighting or arguing with my dad that we
shouldn't put minis of alcohol there
because we make 10
cents on a dollar 35 shot of Crown Royal
you know let's put something that people
actually grab I've always intuitively
that has been my trait my DNA understood
attention what to put in front of it and
that becomes a very simple game that's
how communication works there's a very
specific reason that when there's a coup
d'etat they go after the media first
before they bum-rush even the
president's suite or the dictator suite
they go after the newspaper in the radio
the media is what controls this world
that's what it is
and so if you are not pot committed as
an organization as an individual as a
matter of fact actually let's go
individual why I got a little bit of
time nothing I think is more important
right now for everybody in this room
than them sharing their thoughts on
their expertise on LinkedIn in blog post
form to create opportunities for
themselves in their family without
disrupting where they currently work
nothing you know nothing it is your
absolute insurance policy to your career
you're I love when people get mad about
personal brand words of funny people get
real worked up about words personal
brand charlatan shitty reputation
amazing it's the same [ __ ] so I highly
recommend knowing the makeup of this
room and people might say I'm gonna I'm
an introvert I don't do that I don't
feel comfortable who's gonna care what I
think to me producing content in today's
environment is an offensive move for
your life and your reality and you
should very much consider it I watched
so many people not share their truths in
boardrooms because they know what is
accepted within the company they work in
and they're navigating those waters for
the ability to stay in that company yet
I watched so many people over the last
decade and what I genuinely believe is
gonna happen over the next decade then
lose in that same organization once
traditional wrong thinking is exposed
and that person didn't share their
actual thoughts my friends if you work
in a company let me promise you
something it's a lot more fun
to die on your own sword and so you like
that one it's true it's true people are
about two people to understand and Mark
how many people here to work in
marketing there's a how many people here
work in a company in the marketing
department raise your hands um I want
you to win and I don't want you to
believe something as a marketer that you
don't do because your company doesn't
have reporting that justifies that
behavior which is complete common sense
and then reporting is complete [ __ ]
and you pander to that reporting and in
three years when the company suffers
from pandering to subjective reporting
instead of the reality of the
marketplace you take the fall for
something you didn't believe in in the
first place that's what happens and so
you might not be able to be a dick about
it like I am but what you might be able
to do is respectively respectfully
communicate your point of view in these
rooms and maybe that doesn't play what
you may be able to do carefully is
navigate your opinions on the ecosystem
in your personal blog post which doesn't
expose where you work go a little more
general share your thoughts and those
points of view become your hedge to the
fact that I know the majority of this
room when they work in a company don't
always speak their full truth and that
happens when you go through a time like
this my first ever public business
appearance was a panel at a New Jersey
Chamber of Commerce event that had like
11 people at it and it was me and the
guy who sold yellow pages this is real
sounds like the beginning of a joke
and the joke was on me this was 1998
already 1999 the internet was real but
not to everybody and there was some
back-and-forth and this guy tried to
clown me heavy you know he like he was
like are you gonna believe this kid he's
trying to sell wine on the Internet and
the 11 Joker's in the room laughed at me
and I it's funny how my life evolved
diamond told a story a long time I
remember looking at him and saying you
know I wish this was recorded because
you were gonna be fantastically
historically incorrect I've not seen a
[ __ ] Yellow Pages in five years but I
want to remind everybody the reason so
many companies in the world are called
triple-a something is because hacking
the Yellow Pages in the 40s 50s 60s and
70s meant being the first company listed
under a category and triple-a worked
hacking attention has always played the
place we're in now is remarkable because
of the scale of the Internet itself when
not if when blockchain scales and does
its thing these dynamics will change but
right now there are clearly four to
seven to ten toll booths of the Internet
the Amazons the apples the googles of
the world it is our job in this room to
be the best toll booth collectors we
need to be the next layer we have seen
in many industries people build
companies that just built another toll
booth on top of Google OpenTable right
homeadvisor got it this is what happens
that games changing because we're going
into a much more branding visual world
of the places people's attention is now
Facebook Instagram YouTube audio
podcasting but what made a hit show on
radio in 1937 guiding light which later
became the hit soap opera on television
still plays today which is who can tell
the best story that brings the most
value
I believe stories come in two forms true
entertainment and true utility but you
have to do it for the audience not for
yourself this framework that I've
established tonight to me is the game
this framework is the absolute variable
of the companies that are winning and
losing the unlock to all of this to
become very practical in this room
almost everybody in this room including
me and my companies of my clients is not
in a position to make enough content to
fill the capabilities of these pipes
content has to come down and cost in the
collective the days of spending all that
money on one print ad or one photo like
layout or one video that's a 30-second
spot for the singular video that you
play internally that just doesn't work
we can no longer sell vanilla in a world
where you need to be baskin-robbins and
so I'm excited and this is why I've you
know actions over words why three years
ago I really went all-in and built a
20-person team around my content so like
I'm putting out fifty to a hundred
pieces of content a day like you're so
tired of me it's [ __ ] unbelievable
right like I'm one human you guys are
companies with infrastructure it's time
we stop wasting money it's time we
stopped having wrong strategies that
were built for television and the mail
system like [ __ ] you know it just seems
so crazy to me and I think the most
important part is I think bad marketing
is about to really really rear its head
I really really passionately as a good
Jersey boy who was obsessed with Toys R
Us I passionately walked into their
headquarters six years ago and had this
conversation they just didn't do
anything about it and I think that's the
preview not the anomaly and and I really
really really believe that so I really
really really hope that people
understand the strategy of the talk I
know we're about to do some Q&A I'm
thrilled to take some questions from the
audience I don't know if we're
structured from mattis on this Q&A but
to be honest how you fill them is
something that everybody understood
should understand it's very simple
pictures video audio written word it's
always been the same
just make it valuable empathy for the
actual end consumer is the unlock but
that's just not the framework that
everybody runs in everybody's worried
about themselves and that's why most
people lose that's why most people lose
thank you okay so some people in this
room know I've started five podcasts
right I'm just an audience
yes I'm making some money right so I
know a little bit about that game and I
think that people out here are probably
thinking in themselves how do you track
the ROI on something like that doesn't
have a direct line to revenue how do I
quantity sure I'm getting conversion out
of it how do I know I'm gonna pump a lot
of money into this actually gonna do
something for my business
you don't write guys Nike builds a brand
Apple builds a brand not everything is
quant last guys are we really gonna make
decisions on last touch attribution when
Google disproportionally gets credit for
last touch attribution because of the
way people use Google as their browser
like do you know me people actually saw
a billboard but Google got the credit in
your home I really like and what's funny
about this is when I say stuff like this
very many people react cuz you're all
[ __ ] smart you just play in [ __ ]
systems
I felt that one III think you know many
people here click a banner none zero
zero like I actually want to click one
just to see what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen like like it's it's really sad
that people don't realize that their
basic sales people and they claim to be
marketers mmm like you when you mark it
you do a ton of [ __ ] that doesn't have
black and white ROI within 30 seconds
that's how you build something
meaningful but the appetite for that is
continuously declining because there's
math around it's the same problem that
Google and Facebook have around video
because they have the math around how
many people watch only 3 seconds they
get penalized and then big brands buy
television where there's no math around
that but not a human being
watch as a commercial outside of Super
Bowl watch this real quick just appease
me please stand up right now if you
mainly watch Netflix HBO Go Hulu Amazon
Prime the outside the live sports you
were watching OTT stand up
stick with me stick with me stand up I'm
gonna wait don't be lazy all right now
for the eighth purse to keep standing
I want everybody look around I want to
really look at this for the 8% that's
sitting right who are the only people
that even have a prayer even have a
prayer to see a commercial right every
time they get served a commercial first
of all the ones that are sitting 80% of
them are only watching on DVR this is
outside live sports but even when they
do get served the commercial they
immediately go for their phone they're
not actually consuming it we spend
seventy billion dollars a year in
America doing TV commercials look at
this these same people there's not a
[ __ ] in here who click the banner ad
so this is not about a traditional
versus digital there's bad inventory in
both I think Superbowl is the single bet
you can send thank you very much
I think Superbowl is the single best ad
in marketing because we all see it it's
a sport to consume it you get 100 you
get a hundred percent of American brand
awareness what you fill it with becomes
the variable but yeah man I you know
like it's like marketing is very very
very very understood we're just not
doing it in 2019 there's too much math
and there's too much fear mmm
two weeks ago we did to build up to this
event we did an Instagram live takeover
and they let me take over Magento's
Instagram it was a good decision you
have a very good decision and I you know
a lot of the audience in this room is
actually on Twitter and I got a little
pushback was like why would you push us
to Instagram for content when your
audience is already on Twitter and my
reaction was because that's where human
beings are right well what's your take
on on sort of that channel shift where
where brands exist I pull in the
opposite directions of this I think it
is our job to create no friction for the
consumer
people are Lisa Gary you love digital
why do you write books I'm like because
people read them you know so you know to
me I do think it's important to not
become one-dimensional in one channel
that you're not in control of when
Instagram is your mean the amount of
people that are
beep [ __ ] [ __ ] because they're
completely only Instagram and when
instagrams organic reach falls through
the ground or collapses they're in deep
[ __ ] and what's crazy is we just lived
it on Facebook five minutes ago it's not
like it should be any big surprise it's
coming but people cry
when it happens so here's what I would
say hey I do think it's important when
you have attention somewhere to amortize
it into a lot of places so that your
core audience is and for you as a
business is never one-dimensional but on
the flip side I do think creating
friction for the consumer to consume
your content is a bad idea the reason I
do written word audio and video is I
have no idea how you want to consume me
I just want to give you a chance to
consume me so if you've switched to
audio instead of video watching because
now that's when you run that's what you
do I'm gonna be there in podcast form if
you're sitting at your desk for the
first hour of each day and reading
LinkedIn written word I'm there so I'm
trying to create zero friction for
consumption so one of the questions that
came in over the app earlier today was
yeah I'm a business I'm pretty
successful how do I actually engage my
customers on social if I do b2b are my
customers there and like where do I even
begin I think you know obviously I
started my talk with that because I know
a lot of you and b2b I can't get guys I
my last book crushing it just came out
18 months ago you're not gonna be able
to see it but maybe you can make it out
oh actually
well now it's am crushing it I don't
even talk about LinkedIn it's like I'm
talking like about all these platforms I
talk more about musically in a book I
wrote 18 months ago than LinkedIn didn't
even decide to cover it like was
thinking about and it was like and now
I'm sitting here eighteen months later
and it was like the opening ten minutes
of my talk this is what's so fun about
day trading attention your unemotional I
can't wait to be on stage being like you
do social media [ __ ] social media and I
mean it I really could care less about
social media I care about where your
attention is where it's underpriced and
how do I do
liberal you value that brings me
valuable very basic so you know LinkedIn
is crazy but like honestly like it's
it's at
scale and such virality and such
vibrance because there's not
lengthen has more attention that it has
content filling it which is why this is
how it works you have to get in there
guys you have to so that and podcast I
think every b2b player in here needs to
think about up doing a podcast minimum
Li once a month preferably once a week
and make a podcast that actually brings
value to the employees of the companies
you're trying to reach it doesn't even
have to be it could be about golf if you
think that your industry over indexes on
loving [ __ ] golf as executives it
just needs to hit the CIO the CTO the
CFO bring value own that I'm I'm very
very bullish on that and so I do think I
do believe that you will see the biggest
companies in the world have an
editor-in-chief along with a CMO and a
see you know chief brand officer over
the next decade we will absolutely
become much more publisher than an
advertiser because of consumers non
interest in in advertising and when you
do advertising for example something I'm
very proud of and I'm hope I think some
of you saw because Jesus really got
consumed a couple weeks ago at
vaynermedia we were the agency
creatively and the production house
behind that Dwyane Wade Budweiser spot
right where we retired his jersey and he
did the Jersey swaps if you're gonna do
advertising today it needs to be a
three-minute video that people want to
watch versus a six second pre-roll that
nobody wants to see and so that's what I
think about it another question that
came in was well how do you and you
cover this a little bit earlier how do
you deal with the entrenched bureaucracy
in an organization is it better to bail
yes okay
quit and I'll say why and I'll said why
and I really believe it I think the
reality is is almost every business
cares about short-term economics and
when you care about short-term economics
it almost always goes against what's
right if you were only raising your
child until they were four and they
would leave you would raise them
differently and unfortunately we have a
lot of and I don't believe I used to
blame people but then I'm like no this
is actually the structure I can't be mad
at this CEO she's worked for 37 years
hard to get into this spot and she cares
about maximizing short-term economics
because when she leaves she needs to
sell out her options and she wants it to
be as highly valuable as possible she
doesn't care about that company for the
next 50 years anymore she's an executive
it's not a family business you're not
gonna change it really like you're not
like you like if you work in a company
that is required to create short-term
economics whether that is because
they're a publicly traded company
they're a private company looking to
sell so they're trying to maximize ebody
or they're an early-stage company trying
to raise capital everything's [ __ ] so
yes like if you do not believe the
beauty of being an employee is you get
to leave the lonely part of being an
entrepreneur knowing your company is
it's your fault
and there's nobody else to blame right
like you know the great part of being
employee is even if you suck when you
get fired or like my boss was a dick
you don't have to take an L you know one
question came in on it sort of appealed
to me I'm kind of a sneakerhead
and I saw and I was and they were asking
why k-swiss
and I think that kind of you did a
collab with k-swiss you have a number of
shoes mm-hmm and I have to wonder the
question actually asked you know did you
sell out or is it like the short-term
economics is could you tell that story a
little sure Kent yeah my number one
reason for building my agency is because
I thought that everybody is in big
trouble like I mean I wish I was making
video in 2011 when I really made a
decision
my basic thought was Netflix was gonna
win Facebook was gonna win you know
Amazon was gonna win so I did really
well in investing public companies
private companies and I thought the best
way for me to take advantage of that was
to build the best communication company
machine as I call it infrastructure to
then buy nostalgic brands and reboot
them I believed in nostalgia is the
number one underpriced thing in human
behavior and so k-swiss for me was a
really interesting deal couple things
they reached out to me and so like
anything else you kind of vet that
number to k-swiss meant nothing in
culture when they reached out to me so
any uptick I was gonna get
disproportionate credit for if I did a
deal with Nike or Reebok that would have
been it would be cool but none of what
I'm actually trying to achieve I don't
want to be cool and be an entrepreneur
with sneakers I need to find test cases
for me to test my thesis on am I
actually building an effective machine
that's gonna allow me to buy you know
remember jams shorts I don't know why I
still want to buy that brand and bring
it back for the youngsters it was like a
first version of Zubaz but in shorts
form you know anyway caseless is one of
the best things i've ever done one it
was all upside it was either gonna work
and it would have taught me a lot or it
wasn't gonna work and all my friends
would have made fun of me for being a
dick and thinking I could make a sneaker
right right so it was like no no risk no
I don't I don't feel like I sold out on
it
um no there was there was a mutual value
there that's right yeah a hundred
percent and case was just sold to it to
a Chinese company for a ton of money way
more than they would have didn't do the
deal with me so I feel good about it
they won
I learned a fuckload for what I'm gonna
do next I now look at apparel as an
actual category that I may buy when the
economy collapses instead of just food
which is where I was originally so I've
given myself options when this next
economic decline happens cuz that's what
I'm gonna strike like a Cobra you know
um I mean I literally I can't wait for
the next bear stern I mean it I mean it
like I think that there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on I think there's a lot
of deep layers getting a results but
we're being fake Li propped up so I
think we have time for one more question
this one was sort of heavy I'd love your
take on it
sure do you think we're in an AI arms
race and where do you think that ends
you know one thing I really am
passionate about that's evolved for me
and I'm thankful for it is I try not to
talk about [ __ ] that I don't know mm so
the answer is I'm not sure I haven't
done enough homework on AI to answer
that thoughtfully like the other
questions I think it's inevitable the
technology is inevitable but I think
people grossly underestimate human
beings like we evolved into other [ __ ] I
think AI is gonna do a lot of dumb [ __ ]
that we shouldn't be doing anyway and
and it's going to be impactful but not
the way like I don't think this I think
this could be a precursor to the robots
killing us which I do think is
inevitable I think we'll miss it thank
God but I think our grandkids might be
[ __ ] you know
but I think what a AI is gonna do is and
if you're talking about an arms race
between China and the US if you're
talking about humans vs. robots like
technology eliminates commodity and I
think AI is gonna eliminate a lot of
things that don't bring value in 2026
and I think those humans will find other
things to do listen I got you know for a
lot of first of all thank you so much a
lot of you do follow me a lot of you
know I was a really bad student and I
loved always posting my ridiculously bad
report card but there's one really
interesting insight that I hope helps
everybody here the besides Jim the one
class that I did well in was history and
I've only now started to understand why
I basically use history very heavily to
decide what's gonna happen next
like everybody who's talking about AI is
so bad and like all this like these
articles were written about machinery
around farming we just knew that we were
all farming we went on to do other [ __ ]
like we're gonna do other [ __ ] and by
the way like I don't feel bad for a
truck driver who isn't reading headlines
for 20 years that autonomous trucks are
coming we gave him 20 [ __ ] years like
when they cry in 2039 like oh the
[ __ ] autonomous trucks took me out
I'm like dick you had 20 years you
couldn't have learned another skill
along the way [ __ ] I need this and I
see something clapping listen listen I'm
unbelievably like I have a lot of
different thoughts but I will say this
we are living in the golden era of
entitlement and like the quicker you can
get entitlement out of your body the
better and so yeah like technology
happens I'd much rather be dealing with
the pre-dawn days of AI than dealing
with the Black Plague that happened
to humans they live during a time where
everybody almost [ __ ] died so like
you know like we complain about dumb
[ __ ] you know like the Holocaust was
recent like [ __ ] happens
like I'm not worried about [ __ ] AI
meaning yes a lot of stuff will happen
but I don't view it as this negative
arms race I look at it as phenomenal
because AI is gonna do [ __ ] that below
average humans do poorly which and and I
this is where it's really interesting to
hear that sentence carefully it makes me
then think that that human could
actually then go do something that they
do like and do well that's not like you
suck human you should know it's not some
like rogue [ __ ] it's actually
understanding how humans work which is
when you find something you liked and
you're good at it
life is a lot better than when you don't
or when you just chase money or when you
dwell that the system's against you I
like the pressure of Technology I think
it leads to a lot of happiness for a lot
of people who can just look at the other
side of the coin my friends you find
what you're looking for in life you want
to think everything's negative and
[ __ ] you can find that all day as you
know but if you want to think there's a
ton of opportunity and this is the
greatest era to be alive you can find
that too because the math supports it
pick
I gotta say photo no more questions I
gotta catch my flight yeah good good yep
got it
thank you guys have a wonderful
conference thanks for having me